the war in Ukraine has been raging for
10 months now in the first days of the
war Russia made rapid advances on three
axes threatening to conquer Ukraine's
east south and Center instead the
Russian armies offered a massive
defeater on Kiev then around horkie than
in the southwest around Harrison
Russians are now controlling Crimea
parts of the East and the strip of land
connecting the two they are on the
defensive almost everywhere and have
opted to conduct massive Terror
bombardments of Ukrainian civilian
infrastructure with ballistic missiles
all in all Russians seem to have become
stuck with no Victory inside or have
they lately there has been more and more
talk of a second Russian offensive
against Kiev and ukrainians seem to be
struggling somewhat with the defense of
block mood a strategically important
city in the east as winter approaches
what can we expect on the short mid and
long term will there be a second Battle
of Kiev let's take a look the most
important question to answer first and
foremost is what are the current Russian
war goals in Ukraine and the answer is
the exact same as before the Conquering
of Ukraine now you might think that's
absolutely ludicrous after all those
defeats and humiliations a hundred
thousand casualties and currently 8480
visual confirmed heavy equipment losses
does Putin still seriously intend on
conquering Ukraine yes that Still
Remains the political goal of this war
for Russia and the Russian leadership
plans to achieve this via for example
bombing Ukrainian civilian
infrastructure with ballistic missiles a
war crime to deprive ukrainians of heat
and energy during winter thus degrade
the morale of both the population and
the troops however this plan doesn't
seem to be working though they have done
significant damage to Ukrainian power
facilities most Russian ballistic
missiles are still getting shot down
from their latest massive barrage of 76
missiles 60 were shot down by Ukrainian
air defense with some failing on their
own before even reaching Ukraine
meanwhile partner countries keep
supplying electric equipment and
generators to help keep the Ukrainian
greed operational and so far they've
been successful in addition at the time
of making this video it seems more and
more likely that the US will deliver its
Advanced Patriot air defense systems to
Ukraine which would dull the age of
Russian Terror bombings even further but
ballistic missiles aimed at civilians is
not the only way Putin is trying to get
his way as of the second half of
December 2022 rumors are circulating
about a new Russian offensive against
Kiev the commander of the Ukrainian
military General was quoted saying he
has no doubt they will have another go
at Kiev The Institute for the study of
War assessed such offensive to be
extraordinarily unlikely to succeed
however so far such Minor Details
haven't stopped Russians from trying if
Russians indeed decide to attack they
would need to drag Belarus into the
conflict which Putin seems to be
attempting currently in a very rare
personal visit to Belarus puchin will no
doubt try to pressure lukashenko into
joining The Invasion however for
lukashenko this is extremely dangerous
if the Belarusian Armed Forces get
chewed up inside Ukraine and there is a
very good chance they would that would
weaken lukashenko's rule directly since
the only thing keeping him in power is
Brute Force at this point the bill of
Russian military is in no shape for an
invasion they have around 50 000
military personnel with obsolete
equipment and they cannot throw
everything at Ukraine either because
then who will man the borders who will
keep the order in case people try to
overthrow lukashenko again and so on and
it's not like ukrainians would be caught
by surprise ever since beating the
Russians out to the north they've
established proper defenses along the
Belarusian border if the fresh and
somewhat prepared Russia military
couldn't break the original defenses
that time a worn down Russian military
with ragtag about Russian support
certainly won't break the improved
defenses this time now let's talk about
the Ukrainian objectives the long-term
goal is of course the same remove
Russian troops from the entire territory
of Ukraine the short-term goal is to
keep the Russians at Bay in the East and
gain advantageous positions everywhere
via incremental progress the midterm
goals are far more interesting however
ever since the Ukrainian Victory and
Russian withdrawal in Harrison there has
not been any major breakthroughs along
the front lines that was due to the
Ukrainian mud season which makes
large-scale Maneuvers practically
impossible however that certain cold
season is coming in a few weeks the
ground will freeze solid enabling
Maneuvers once again and this is when I
believe Ukraine will start another
large-scale offensive but where in the
South the two armies are separated by
the massive nipro River trying to attack
through it would be incredibly difficult
and the ukrainians would run into
prepared Russian defensive lines on the
other side in the East ukrainians are
holding the line and grinding down
frustrated Russian assaults this is the
buckmut area and or making incremental
advances towards criminal and swatovia
in order to cut a major supply line for
Russian troops in the area the Frontline
are largely aesthetic there I personally
doubt we'll be seeing any major
offensives in that area in the near
future but I could be wrong of course
this leaves us with the southeast a
large flat open area north of which the
Ukrainian military has been massing for
months not coincidentally this is the
most likely area for a large-scale
Ukrainian defensive which I believe
we'll be seeing in the coming months the
main objective of the winter offensive
would be to take tokmok and Military
Paul both being major Supply hubs thus
cutting Russian forces in half
geographically speaking if ukrainians
managed to pull it off I'm fairly
certain that would be the beginning of
the end for the Russian invasion and why
is that currently Russian troops south
of hearthstone and in Crimea can be
supplied via two routes one through
military and the other through Carriage
however the carriage has been damaged
and is out of commission for heavy
military echelons for at least half a
year or so Russians therefore have to
resort to ferrying the plastic Crimea
which is slow ineffective and vulnerable
if the meditable Supply route would be
cured the cared Trader would be
struggling to supply both the Russian
invasion force and the civilian
population of Crimea at that point
Russia would find itself in a situation
like Harrison only on a larger scale
where they have a whole lot of troops
dug in connected by a crippled supply
line slowly being ground down by
Ukrainian strikes and assaults but this
I believe is on the farther end of the
Ukrainian midterm goals so where does
all this put Russian mobilization
efforts can Russia come out with a messy
wave of fresh troops to overwhelm
Ukrainian Defenders and achieve their
War goals no the Soviet mobilization
infrastructure is largely gone what
remains cannot cope with the sheer
number of new recruits Beyond huge
issues with training including the leg
thereof equipping those soldiers is also
either subpar or doesn't happen many
Russian mobile lines have to buy their
own gear before heading into the combat
zone such recruits can keep Ukrainian
Defenders busy but aren't good for much
else such as complex combined arms
Maneuvers I expect that the lack of
proper equipment will become an
especially severe problem during the
Cold Case in point it's not even the
dead of winter yet but we've already
seen Russian troops affected by
hyperthermia due to lack of winter gear
soldiers also need to be fed more during
the cold as the body burns more calories
to keep warm with the current degraded
inefficient Russian supply lines will
likely see food shortages among Russian
troops further decreasing their combat
capabilities if a well-supied UK any
military attacks then things could get
very ugly very fast for the Russians to
sum up winter is bound to be pretty hot
in Ukraine the initiative remains firmly
with ukrainians and Putin or his General
surovicin likely won't be able to change
that especially with an ill-fated second
assault on Kiev and if ukrainians
managed to take many people in the South
and reach the sea it would be a game
changer for this whole conflict and
would Mark the beginning of the end for
the Russians
[Music]